unlv health schools are teaming up for a
poverty simulation the goal is to build
empathy and expose students to the
impacts of poverty here in our community
mary jane belliesa shares how students
are reacting as they transition into
their medical careers
this poverty simulation is an
interactive simulation teaching medical
dental and nursing students what it's
like for those living near or on the
poverty line students will encounter
obstacles as they navigate through daily
tasks like managing transportation needs
or applying for jobs organizer mini wood
says this exercise will help teach
students how to serve and provide
quality care to low-income individuals
poverty is not an issue of individual
failure or individual responsibility but
it's a systemic and structural issue
they can you know understand how all of
our structures and systems interact
together to create tremendous barriers
and obstacles for people who are trying
to get out of poverty dental student
yulin lee says there is a constant
struggle to meet basic needs at first it
seemed very like superficial easy but
now that i'm actually
in the situation and see how the family
is like trying to figure out
how to get to places how to pay for like
mortgage and stuff kind of kind of hit
me i think those were things that i was
very oblivious to honestly nursing
student silo mamaclay is given the role
of an elderly woman citing financial
insecurity and neglect as big issues
among seniors it's our job to be
compassionate and be empathetic towards
people you never really know who you're
going to be taking care of whether
they're homeless elderly being abused if
they have no insurance so
this is really eye-opening reporting
from the paul mcdermott education center
at unlv mary jane vallieza live local
now